comme un air de retour à la normale ce
lundi l'italie a rouvert les portes de
ses écoles
[Musique]
restaurant ou encore cinéma
un déconfinement progressif qui entre en
vigueur pour les régions classée en
jaune soit le niveau le plus bas de
risque sanitaire
les écoles accueillent 70% des effectifs
en présentiel une présence total n'étant
pas possible du fait des transports
toujours limité un retour dans les
établissements scolaires qui sonne comme
un soulagement pour les élèves
il est certain qu'on retour à presque
100% nous aident en tant qu'étudiant
donc nous espérons que nous pourrons
continuer comme salle pour les derniers
mois pour nous en particulier qui
sûrement cinquième année être en
cinquième année et préparer un examen
final avec l'apprentissage en présentiel
et sûrement mieux que de le faire depuis
chez soi et du côté de la culture les
cinémas et les musées peuvent à nouveau
accueillir du public à hauteur de 50% et
avec un contrôle systématique de la
température à l'entrée un protocole
strict mise en place également pour les
restaurants qui sont autorisés à servir
en terrasse et le soir jusqu'au couvre
feu de 22 heures un scénario inédit
depuis six mois qui permet à près de
140000 bars restaurants et pizzerias de
rouvrir leurs portes
je suis très heureux de pouvoir utiliser
les petites tables à l'extérieur à
partir d'aujourd'hui malheureusement le
temps n'est pas au beau fixe mais on
espère que pendant la semaine
les choses vont s'améliorer au moins
nous avons une chose de plus à offrir
aux gens c'est un peu une renaissance à
partir du 1er juillet piscine salle de
sport et parcs d'attractions devrait
connaître le même sort après des mois
d'ouvertures et de fermetures à
répétition
l'italie espère pouvoir profiter de la
période estivale
mais selon les spécialistes un nouveau
pic de contagion pourrait compromettre
l'été des italiens sur un territoire qui
enregistre actuellement 300 décès par
jour en moyenne
l'italie l'un des pays les plus durement
touchés par le cos vide avec près de 120
mille décès souffre d'une violente crise
économique
c'est dans ce contexte que mario draghi
a présenté ce lundi devant le parlement
son plan de relance de 190 milliards
d'euros
un plan financé par l'union européenne
sur lequel se jouera le destin de
l'italie selon le chef du gouvernement